you're watching the Valley's most
accurate forecast on 8 news now yeah we
will check in with your family and
friends across the country and talk
about those tornadoes but we want to
start here at home another beautiful
live picture this from our camera on top
of the Bank of America building the
Molasky family companies over 95 in
Rainbow looking out to the East do you
have some scattered high clouds couple
of jet trails you might notice a little
bit of brown Haze here because of a lack
of wind well that's going to change over
the next 24 to 48 hours we also want to
check in on your neighborhood
temperatures we know it's 51 officially
out at Reed International but as we keep
an eye on the big picture here let's
zero into your neighborhood how cool is
it to have anybody in the 40s yes
there's 49 right now at Summerlin a lot
of neighborhoods we're in the mid 30s a
coupling them dipping down to the lower
30s Mountains Edge you're up to 51 right
now same with the Lakes warm spot that's
going to be the Air Force Base at 55.
wind again not a factor today it will be
later tomorrow maybe lingering into
Friday day and then for sure coming back
again Saturday and Sunday but let's
stick with some more right now numbers
actually a little bit warmer right now
up in Ely when we talk about this system
up in the Pacific Northwest that's
dumping a lot of snow in the higher
elevations of Washington and Oregon it
may bring some snow to Reno maybe as far
south as Central Nevada possibly Lincoln
County Caliente you are at 48 but we're
not anticipating precipitation here in
the Las Vegas area perhaps in the
dusting up on the mountain so we'll try
for 58 today we made it to 56 yesterday
there's the official low this morning 36
well below normal so here's what's going
on there's that system in the Pacific
Northwest already snowing right now in
lower Idaho and maybe dipping into
extreme Northern Nevada and there's
clouds scraping down to the South and to
the east of us now if there's any good
news from all those tornadoes from
yesterday this system is moving rapidly
off the Mid-Atlantic Coastal States now
there's a lot of rain for Upstate New
York and of course turning into snow as
you get into Eastern Canada
let's talk about the right now
temperatures yeah still in the teens
across the north uh 37 right now in
Kansas City so that cold air mixing with
the warmer moisture air that's still got
those showers going along along the
coast but they are moving off here is
your most accurate eight day forecast
more wind tomorrow 60 58 with some
clouds Friday and Saturday windy again
Saturday and Sunday up to 62 for Sunday
but then that next round of wind ushers
in some cooler temperatures Ted florindo
updates your weather later this
afternoon John all right need thank you
very much